ce geste fumer une cigarette
vous ne pourrez plus le faire en toute
liberté monsieur jean conrad le ralph
nader français explique la décision que
vient de prendre le ministère de la
santé publique
un bon ministre après consultation
naturellement avec le gouvernement et
avec le ministre de l'environnement a
décidé la suppression de la licence que
constituait la possibilité de fumer dans
les lieux publics
désormais tous les français devront s'y
conformer qu'entendez vous par les lieux
publics
le l'expression elle même est assez
clair on n'est ce pas tous les lieux où
d'autres personnes se trouvent en même
temps que vous vous vous seul fumée ou
d'autres personnes peuvent ne pas
comment dirais-je tolérer la fumée et a
fortiori ne pas subir la position que
vous leur infliger croyez vous que cette
mesure sera facile à faire appliquer
certainement pas chacun sait que le
français très individualiste qu'il croit
beaucoup à ses droits et plus à ses
devoirs mais nous pensons que la police
y ont atteint un tel degré n'est ce pas
que tous les français comprendront que
leurs intérêts se trouve dans
l'obéissance ou disons aux conseils
éclairés du gouvernement on estime que
60 % des français sont fumeurs petits ou
gros
or une étude du royal college de londres
montre qu'à 35 ans un gros fumeur
environ deux paquets de cigarettes par
jour à 4 fois plus de chances de mourir
dans les dix ans à venir cas non fumeurs
ce fumeur trop souvent ils empoisonnent
le non fumeur
il n'y aura plus loin de le faire
l'interdiction de fumer dans tous les
lieux où se tiennent des réunions
professionnelles de plus de quatre
personnes
par exemple la conférence de rédaction
de 24 heures sur la deux l'interdiction
de fumer dans les ascenseurs d'immeubles
privés ou publics
interdiction de fumer dans les halls de
gare dans les couloirs du métro dans les
expositions interdiction de fumer dans
les magasins chez tous les commerçants
dans les cafés
aussi bien aux terrasses qu'à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
interdiction de fumer dans les jardins
publics
et puis et surtout dans la rue ce qui
provoque quelques réactions monsieur
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics
or moi je trouve que c'est normal
d'abord chypre aux fumeurs mais ça le
gêne énormément travaillé quelques à
côtés de moelle
la porte s'ouvre la fenêtre j'ai tout le
temps la fumée dans les yeux comme par
hasard ça c'est une très bonne chose
j'ai appris ça ce matin et c'est très
bien
c'est une atteinte directe à la liberté
individuelle et jusqu'à seulement contre
j'ai envie de fumer je fais bien doit
fumer oui mais vous ne pensez pas que ça
peut gêner les gens dans la rue dans la
rue dans la rue belleau fuir les
voitures encore vous aurez de quoi ce
matin-là rateur oui c'est la radio j'ai
entendu parler de ça effectivement c'est
peut-être autre chose car nous dans nos
magasins moi j'ai une petite boutique
c'est vraiment intenable dans les
cachots et pourquoi
faut pas gêner les autres consommateurs
ceux qui n'aiment pas d'appuyer ceux qui
songent décembre je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose
pourquoi parce que les hommes en général
ce sont pas très galant et ils nous
envoient des vous fait de fumer dans les
yeux et leur cigarette partout c'est
très déplaisant ne fut marathon plus ce
n'est pas l'avis de la régie française
des tabacs la production de la régie
française des tabacs ne sera pas affecté
par cette nouvelle loi car il est
évident qu'on ne pourra pas empêcher les
vrais fumeurs de fumer une cigarette
dans la rue et notre part nous avons
davantage à la régie d'avoir un service
de recherche qui vient de mettre une
cigarette au point complètement
inoffensive et anti pollution qui ne
produira pas de fumer dans les
cigarettes intel sur le marché haut dans
six mois à peu près et nous détruirons
1,6 est ce dieu principe qui est de dire
pas de feu sans fumée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]